écoutez toujours une situation d'extrême
tension et de batailles rangées au
centre de l'esplanade charge surcharge
beaucoup de gaz lacrymogène en a vu d
une charge et très violente de la brave
avec des interpellations consécutive la
tout à l'heure on entendait le chiffre
de 2 16 interpellations dont on a vu
deux ici derrière moi en fait alors ici
c'est un peu plus calme on s'est mis en
retrait parce que ça devenait vraiment
irrespirable on pleurait beaucoup en
fait il ya même des scènes de
fraternisation presque entre les forces
de l'ordre et les soignants est ici donc
un peu d'accalmie mais ils ont mis en
marche
le camion doté de canons à eau donc
j'imagine que c'est l'étape suivante
pour disperser les manifestants en
nombre mais pour nous parler de cette
manifestation qui a été gâchée
évidemment par les nombreuses
échauffourées je suis avec absa bas qui
est aide soignante
alors elle ça va vous qu'est ce que vous
avez pensé cette manifestation
donc la manifestation au début a bien
commencé
tout s'est bien passé aventures de mots
le cortège a démarré on a commencé nos
champs de l'eau slogan tout un coup ils
ont commencé à casser
donc à nous gazer moi je trouve
inadmissible le fait qu'on vienne pour
voilà en fait réclamer nos droits et
nous du compte on retrouve en fait
encercler comme des voleurs à se faire
gazer avoir les yeux qui pleurent de nez
qui pique avec des bombes lacrymogènes
c'est tout à fait et en soignant que
c'est très dangereux et demain je trouve
ça inadmissible et le fait que voilà
nous on met quand même notre santé en
jeu pour venir en aide à la population
et qu'on se retrouve en fait en cercle
et comme des voleurs je trouve ça
inadmissible et faudrait peut-être que
le gouvernement se rêver parce que c'est
bien beau d derrière un bureau est de
donner des conseils mais quand on est
sur le terrain même ce n'est pas la même
chose actuellement les hôpitaux son
manque de matériel en manque d'effectif
ça je le dis haut et fort on se retrouve
maintenant avec des
dans des services avec 23 patients pour
en affirmer une étonnante trouve ça
inadmissible
donc nous on est diffusé on n'est pas
écoutés on se sent délaissé il faudrait
que l'état fasse quelque chose sinon ça
ça risque de mal finir
parce que vu que on nous prend comme des
délinquants bas s'ils continuent comme
ça les gens vont se prendre contre les
délinquants le problème aussi c'est
qu'aujourd'hui il ya des éléments
radicaux qui sont allé provoquer la
police le souci c'est que c'est ça a été
aussi les gazelles ont concerné aussi
des soignants c'est ça le problème
voilà moi comme j'ai dit je trouve
injuste le fait que nous mêmes nous tous
dans le même sac
parce que c'est vrai qu'il ya eu des
casseurs c'est les casseurs mais nous
les soignons une venus pacifiquement et
je trouve inadmissible qu'il fasse un
mélange de tout le monde est là il n'y a
pas de soignants ni casseurs on est
mélangé
on nous gave nous tous et puis voilà
voilà le vécu d'hassaba une aide
soignante inquiète mme sy a témoigné des
difficultés à des soignants général
évidemment dans cette période de crise
sanitaire un des besoins de moyens je
rappelle les revendications à des
revalorisations salariales
une création de lits l'arrêt de la
fermeture des lits et des rustres
restructurations l'arrêt de la
tarification à l'acte mais évidemment
toutes ces revendications sont un peu
moins audible avec les échauffourées en
ce moment vous entendez certainement
derrière moi des bruits de grenade ebodé
et puis il ya encore des charges à
nombreux des des gaz lacrymogènes qui
vole avec une averse et des canons à eau
en préparation donc voilà pour
l'ambiance en ce moment sur l'épreuve
des invalides
katia on voit d'ailleurs que
et certains manifestants cours
continuent de provoquer lancent des
projectiles vers les forces de l'ordre
pour les provoquer il ya ce tweet katia
la technique de la préfecture de police
de paris
le voici des groupes violents qui
tentent de faire dégénérer la
manifestation pacifique des soignants la
préfecture de police qui appelle au
calme et à la responsabilité des
individus virulents il ya eu seize
interpellations 4 sa technique est ce
que vous vous avez pu vous avez des
informations sur ces manifestants qui
sèment le trouble en marge de ce
rassemblement à paris que vous avez peu
de dire v6 nous si vous voulez les
manifestants étant oui ils sont cagoulés
ils sont masqués donc si vous voulez les
informations elles sont assez limités
tout le monde court dans tous les sens
et une scène de chaos comme le rappelait
l aide soignante si vous voulez tout le
monde se fait gazer sans distinction que
ce soit les éléments radicaux le black
block 1 qui qui a qui est présent
aujourd'hui très présent et très
virulent si vous voulez malheureusement
tout le monde est logé à la même
enseigne
tous les professionnels les syndicats
les élus tout le monde à a reçu des gaz
lacrymogènes et éventuellement des
charges quand on ne court pas assez vite
ce qui est clair c'est bien entendu il
ya des éléments radicaux pour une
manifestation de soignants ils sont
extrêmement nombreux
a eu d'autres et avec moins de
débordements mais là comme tout le monde
est bloquée si vous voulez sur
l'esplanade des invalides
les gens sont comme dans une souricière
donkey à charge contre chaps les gens
courent ils se remettent en position et
puis les forces de l'ordre recharge je
pense que maintenant l'étape c'est les
canons à eau sur les éléments bon on
sait très bien qu'ils sont des éléments
radicaux et et du black block qui
évidemment ne se cache pas de de faire
ce type d'action aujourd'hui mais vous
imaginez qu avec les masques jordi
évidemment beaucoup de manifestants
quelques histoires porte des masses donc
plus les cagoules évidemment on on a
très très peu d'informations sûres sur
les éléments qui provoquent la police
est donc vous parler des canons à eau
ce sera probablement au moment de la
dispersion qu'il faut s'attendre
peut-être à des tensions
plus forte là d'ici là la dispersion pas
votre avis il m'a écouté
oui en fait si vous voulez on a vu sur
les tweets que il parlait déjà de
dispersion alors qu'actuellement il ya
énormément de personnes sur la place qui
n'ont absolument pas envie d'être
dispersées qui sont toujours sur les de
la manifestation mais tout à l'heure le
canon à eau n'avait pas été mis en
marche en fait là on va le camion je
dirais le moteur a été enclenchée ce qui
signifie que quelque chose se prépare
donc pour pour la suite c'est évident
mais là je vois encore les gens courir
dans tous les sens c'est encore
extrêmement actif au point de vue des
détentions et des options et que les
porteuses énormément de deux jets de
projectiles à nos journalistes a été
blessée d'ailleurs c'est grave on sur la
jambe enfin il a quand même pris
certainement une pierre dans la salle
courant on voit énorme s'il vous plaît
depuis tout à l'heure il ya des jets de
gaz lacrymogène d'une part vraiment
d'une épaisseur assez considérable et
c'est en permanence depuis plusieurs
heures
merci beaucoup beaucoup il écrit des
jauges oui bah oui je vous dise c'est
vraiment une scène un peu de chaos ya
toujours du mobilier qui brûle en fait
le mobilier urbain attendez je vais je
me déplace un peu pour qu'on puisse voir
un peu si vous voulez voir le mobilier
urbain brûle les gens courent dans tous
les sens et
et les les forces de l'ordre ges jette
donc des gaz lacrymogènes donc comme
vous voyez il reste encore beaucoup de
l'individu de soignants de tous types de
manifestants sur la place qui ne veulent
pas partir évidemment il est ce parce
que les soignants depuis le départ ne
veulent pas quitter la place puisque
c'est l'heure oui oui absolument tout à
l'heure les syndicats ont fait une
annonce en disant on ne va pas
abandonner le terrain nous sommes nous
sommes là pour revendiquer et on va pas
laisser ces affrontements gâcher anneaux
notre journée de protestation de
revendications donc oui il ya encore des
soignants alors même si les si vous
voulez les camions des syndicats ont
quitté pour la plupart la place en
envoie un peu qu'ils sont en train de
justement de ma de quitter les lieux
mais sinon il reste encore à des
soignants on voit les blouses blanches
clairement il en reste et les soignants
katia technique vous les avez entendus
je prends mon milieu d'après-midi ils
sont dépités cc syndicats
[Musique]
alors moi j'ai pas forcément interviews
des syndicalistes mais chez les
soignants oui ils ont ils sont déçus si
vous voulez ils sont déçus que ça et
tourner comme ça alors certains blâment
aujourd'hui les individus qui ont
provoqué la police d'autres noms ont
préféré constater le fait que quoi quel
que soit le mode d'action l'aller
quelles que soient les revendications
finalement ils ne sont pas entendus
donc pour eux c'est une journée de plus
d une journée de plus durant laquelle
ils sont dans la rue et selon eux ça
tourne encore court en fait donc il ya
une sorte de de lassitude dans la
profession qui est désespéré de voir que
quels que soient les moyens à employer
donc les les grèves des urgences le fait
d'aller dans la rue eh bien il n'arrive
pas du tout à leur fin ils n'arrivent
pas à faire entendre leurs
revendications qui sont évidemment
davantage de moyens comme disait tout à
l'heure et l'arrêt de la fermeture des
lits et autres revendications qui sont
pas très précises et qui sont toujours
pas entendus merci beaucoup katia
technique